today raising cane's opened a new  location on the las vegas strip it's a  two-story restaurant first of its kind  in the nation regional vice president  stephen short explains why there was no  better place to kick off this style of  restaurant  we just wanted to bring this down to the  strip with all the stuff that's going on  in las vegas everything that's happened  we're just going to be more pleased to  be here of course it's a las vegas strip  is there anything bigger than las vegas  strip today  in true vegas fashion this location  features a seven foot elvis neon light  throughout this is the 14th location in  las vegas you can check out the new  restaurant on las vegas boulevard it is  open elvis and chicken strips you can't  get more vegas than that right